with all these intense scenes what was
the atmosphere that was created on set
to make this happen
our director Andrew Neil did a really
good job of creating a safe environment
upset you know we went as far as to have
a safe word which I feel like was
important some of these moments were so
so heavy we only had to use safe word
once but the environment was very safe
you know and but also not not being too
fragile with it I think that there was
almost you know there was a lot of
Andrew pulling the the fraternity
brothers aside and the pledges were in a
different room you know so that he
wanted that fear to be there a little
bit and for it to be slightly
uncomfortable in moments but we always
knew that we had a safety net that was
never going to go to a point where
anyone felt you know like they weren't
safe if they weren't comfortable so it
was a good environment so how did you
guys blow off steam the of these intense
scenes was what what did you do - for
fun to lighten things up after these
intense scenes after some of these
intense scenes you know we were really
limited on what we could do speed so
little time to shoot it but you know a
beer after shooting and kind of
decompressing all of us just talking and
you know there was a great feeling
amongst the boys that we needed to
support each other outside of the set
and so yeah a few nights with a beer and
a cigar and just kind of kick him back
and trying to relax a little bit
and just talking you know you need to
sort of work through it a little bit
yeah does this affect your music career
and for instance did this experience
inspire you to write any new material
this experience was inspiring in a lot
of ways you know I think the the biggest
was was just going to a different
artistic and creative place being
challenged by you know other actors in
the director just pushed me to push
myself harder you know and dig deep and
and write things that that you know were
as gripping to me as the the film work
was you know so I think your art has to
when you have
couple different is going on so kind of
go at the same level parallel or that
imbalance can be a little crazy but it
was nice to to be able to blow off steam
by just going and writing you know
creating doing something different
because this film did take a lot out of
me
in what way uh it was just an emotional
roller coaster you know six weeks of
just like really being in the trenches
you need a little bit of fun afterwards
and just kind of spaced out a little bit
James Franco anything surprising from
working with him well I'm not sure I was
too surprised I kind of expected the
experience to be really unique and
interesting but he came in and was just
guns blazing just on fire and kind of
blew all of our minds and his character
is this sort of legacy fraternity
brother who comes back and says he's
gonna have one drink and cut to not one
drink but it was it was funny I think
we're supposed to be in the scene
incredibly fascinated by this guy and
you know thinking he's the man and it
wasn't too far off from reality I think
well all those young men and actors were
just so excited to be in the room with
with James and also his creative input
on the film as a producer it was great
and you know overall it was just a
really amazing experience